congrats guys yes congrats to you
because the spot thank you
very inspiring you guys are killing it
um I mean there's been a lot of uh
you know a lot of narratives about you
guys have popped up on a lot of places
so I think this probably is this the
first time besides your own platforms
you guys have been on camera talking
about this because you guys have been on
like academics thing yeah on camera yeah
this is the first thing I told I told
everybody we weren't gonna uh talk about
nothing until we was all together but uh
you know since we like you I'm glad that
I'm pungent to come to pack me out yeah
put them put them whooping ass right now
he been whooping ass all week Jesus I
mean sometimes you need that you know
what I'm saying so we can relax and do
our thing
um give me like an idea of what fig
Community world is gonna be because
obviously uh the Youtube channel was
started a while ago
here we go
is that where we're gonna no I'm just I
I you know when you go to the page
um good there's a bunch of y'all on
there obviously smack you pun duno
um who like like is it gonna be because
the Wednesday show is obviously
something that the fans are gonna miss
you guys are going to be doing your own
version of that we're doing Wednesdays
live I mean so yeah fig Community World
basically is our Network so we'll just
definitely become no jumper we'll ease
into that you know somewhere it's a
bunch of uh podcasts and different shows
different Vlogs like you know different
series and stuff like that so we'll
we'll we'll begin with what we already
have right now which is uh a Wednesday
show and we named it we renamed it shame
on you instead at the end of the day and
uh we'll take the um we hungry show
which is their food show great show by
the way we starving or something yeah
it's hard to do a food show with
somebody who only likes to eat french
fries okay he gotta change his palette
are you saying you have white trash food
uh taste because no no no I mean my
favorite food is french fries so don't
hate on me he goes to nice hotels give
me your French fries see that White Band
with the headphones on over there same
thing all he does is eat fries
are they selling macaroni and cheese
more french fries as a side
okay yeah I mean I think I told y'all I
think I told you all like it like last
year I was like you know this I felt
like what was happening that was
inevitable you know I think you cracked
it off
I don't know
look at you stirring up [__]
no I might I might have I think I told
y'all like hey man like you guys know
you guys could be like for real the
drink Champs of the [__] uh do you
say that first so even off camera he was
like oh you and t-real can take this
[__] to the next level I was like
hmm so how how
everybody be like do it do it do it I'm
like how [__] I don't know how like man
I'm just only I'm trying to figure it
out right yeah that's the thing you just
gotta figure it out then once you figure
it out like okay this is what they were
talking about all right now let's take
the steps toward what we need to do we
thought with our life you know what I'm
saying in the show I mean we it was like
like I was saying it was inevitable
already you know what I'm saying we just
had to make that move a little faster
just due to whatever whatever had to you
know happen to A.D or whatever the case
may be like all right well [__] it it's
just time so let's just you know what
I'm saying pack up and put our big boy
boots on and let's do it anyway you know
what I'm saying and that's just what
happened but the [__] was gonna happen
anyway was it already in motion the [__]
was in motion like months ago I already
had this and that and that's because of
the page so people were saying that
they've been made the page yeah I've
been made that [__] for sure yeah I mean
because that was me
everybody else
don't say he did it I'm gonna say I did
it in February we all gonna take the
blame yeah no but that's you know that's
due to
um
our situation didn't [__] dinner you
know if you try to cut our water off we
got to make sure we do what we supposed
to do you know like the camaraderie of
it seemed like the ship was sinking
right and we're like wait a minute it
did feel that way yeah I think you and I
were talking when the when the battle
rap [__] was happening I'm like what the
[__] going on over there bro
you guys are [__] dissing each other
I mean but it was just one day you know
just one day and you know like I said
that [__] you know I'm not I wasn't put
to ease with that [__] I was uneasy you
know what I'm saying when a [__]
just wake up one day like yo I'ma cancel
all this [__] and then I look and I'm
like [__] you don't have a backup plan
we got [__] I mean I have well we was
already doing our own shows or whatever
the case may be you know we was growing
speaking of that fig Community is like
number two in all podcasts
man yeah thank you man congrats I saw
that I was like
your buddy slot bruh is that a big thing
even if it's a big deal
serious let's get to the number one even
if it's even if it's two three days
since you're up there two days is a big
deal because usually you can pop up
there and then like it's three hours and
then yeah you know what I noticed I'm
looking at that [__] and I said why the
[__] is our [__] under entertainment
news
hmm
instead of music so we got to switch
that [__] up man hey stay in
entertainment news man yeah
get in there
they don't want to run that genre right
here get in that [__] I might
switch my [__] no no no number two yeah
Joe Budden Heather smack I like that
y'all need a uh like you guys are
Entertainment Network kind of you guys
do do music [__] you know what I'm
saying but it ain't strictly a music you
know it's time to step up it's time to
step up to something new